>>> WE'RE BACK TO HURRICANE IAN
IN FLORIDA HERE IN A MOMENT BUT
FIRST A POTENTIAL BREAK THROUGH
THIS MORNING FOR MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS AFFECTED BY
ALZHEIMER'S.
A NEW ANTIBODY TREATMENT FOR THE
DISEASE COULD SLOW THE
PROGRESSION OF COGNITIVE DECLINE
BY 27%.
HERE TO EXPLAIN THIS MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT IS CNN CHIEF MEDICAL
CORRESPONDENT AND AUTHOR OF
"KEEP SHARP BUILD A BETTER BRAIN
AT ANY AGE" DR. SANJAY GUPTA.
SANJAY, THIS IS SO IMPORTANT TO
TALK ABOUT BECAUSE PAST -- YOU
KNOW, PAST MEDICATIONS HAVE
IMPROVED COGNITION PERHAPS BUT
NOT THAT MUCH.
THIS IS A BIG NUMBER.
>> IF THIS HOLDS UP, IF THIS
DATA HOLDS UP, SO FAR WE'VE JUST
HEARD FROM THE MANUFACTURER OF
THE PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES
THEMSELVES, BUT IF IT HOLDS UP
IT COULD BE A VERY BIG DEAL IN
THE WORLD OF ALZHEIMER'S.
THERE'S NOT BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
TREATMENT THAT HAS HAD THIS
DEGREE OF IMPROVEMENT IN THESE
PATIENTS REALLY IN A LONG TIME,
IF EVER.
SO LET ME SORT OF TALK YOU
THROUGH THIS.
IT'S A NEW DRUG.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN WATCHING FOR SOME TIME.
LIKINOMAB.
1800 PEOPLE WITH EARLY STAGE
ALZHEIMER'S.
PART OF THE GROUP GOT THE DRUG,
THE OTHER GROUP GOT PLACEBO.
WHAT THEY FOUND AFTER 18 MONTHS,
BRIANNA, WAS THERE WAS A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN OVERALL
COGNITIVE WORSENING IN THE GROUP
THAT GOT THE DRUG.
THIS IS THE THING.
THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING FOR FOR SOME TIME NOW.
WE KNOW PEOPLE WITH ALZHEIMER'S,
THEY CONTINUE TO PROGRESS IN
TERMS OF COGNITIVE DECLINE.
IF THIS COULD SLOW THAT DOWN,
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT.
NOW A COUPLE THINGS.
THE WAY THAT THEY MEASURE THIS,
THIS COGNITIVE DECLINE, THEY
ASKED QUESTIONS ABOUT MEMORY,
ABOUT ORIENTATION, ABOUT 27%,
THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THAT BIG
OF A NUMBER, BUT IN TERMS OF
YOUR OVERALL ABILITY TO
FUNCTION, YOUR ABILITY TO
FUNCTION IN YOUR EVERYDAY LIFE
IT CAN MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE FOR
SOMEBODY IN TERMS OF EARLY STAGE
ALZHEIMER'S HOW WELL THEY CAN
FUNCTION INDEPENDENTLY OR IN A
HOME SETTING.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A BIG TOPIC
OF DISCUSSION AS WELL.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DRUG, IT
DID HAVE AN EFFECT ON THE
PLAGUES IN THE BRAIN.
THE AMYLOID PLAGUES.
THERE WAS A DECREASE IN THE
PLAGUES YOU SEE ON THE RIGHT
SIDE OF THE SCREEN.
WHETHER THOSE TWO THINGS ARE
DIRECTLY CONNECTED OR NOT IS
STILL UNCLEAR BECAUSE AS YOU
CORRECTLY POINT OUT, BRIANNA,
THERE HAVE BEEN DRUGS IN THE
PAST WHICH ARE VERY GOOD AT
GETTING RID OF THE PLAGUES BUT
DIDN'T DO MUCH IN TERMS